I know I'm welcome to tell you all these
probably basic scratch offs as you can
see here we're doing an ROI task which
is return on investment it will be in
groups of three and you have got to swim
a hundred pounds each on the stage of
that it wanted everyone to win the
hundred pound each what they're gonna
look done is ring the agents have been
really transparent tell them what
they're looking for you know be specific
it's gonna be honest and truthful and be
really polite to the agent as well as do
as much research and due diligence as
they can to when they're speaking to the
agent they're finding out what the rent
prices are how much can they achieve in
rent
[Music]
[Music]
all right so what are your names
what's your name Heidi oh sorry what
Anya Anya Oh Sam
sue sue I heard that one at least that's
good guys I'm not gonna give my opinion
on this you guys are gonna give your
opinion because you are the judges so
let's have a look
all right so fifty-five thousand pounds
let's have a look at the condition I
mean it depends on what the judges said
nice bathroom
do we like do we like it or not there's
a few people that I'm not sure but the
general consensus is that it's okay tell
me what market research and due
diligence she did on this house we went
on right did come yeah mass price and we
actually found only one property that
was sold in 2015 for forty two thousand
three key that's this house so yep all
right said this house 142 but that was
that was a four years ago so uh what's
the rent we thinking like on the kind of
very conservative side 550 and we yes
because we found even more than that
even over 600 and all right we're gonna
need I think these guys want to see some
kind of proof yeah there's similar house
on right more fair for 552 renting well
I think we're gonna look on open rent so
get ready to give me the postcode again
any 540 are for junior this is a three
bed okay okay okay fair enough this is
too bad it's gone for 450 so you're
suggesting that this will rent out for
how much 550 I don't know
I think I have a feeling I ever felt I
was feeling people it's thinking
probably 500 what person might not just
show that's my - oh so have you spoken
to any of the agents yes I have who you
speak to remember the names
okay but really definitely the name was
a Latin angel or was it this estate
agent a lighting agent and what did they
tell you he said
550 is reasonable price and did you
pretend to be a tenant or did you tell
them that you're an investor tenant so
let me have a look at your return on
investment sheet because at the end of
the day it's the numbers that have you
got the ROI sheet you're working out let
me say so you're working that's I can
just read it all right okay well don't
okay thank you thank you so you're
saying that you're gonna put in 14 and a
half thousand on the basis that you're
buying it for fifty five fifty how did
you speak to the agent did they say that
that was going to happen though nobody's
been on the market for like six months
now from the market for six months he's
not selling no okay all right well if
you did buy it for 50,000 you'd need to
put in yeah 14 and a half that's correct
all right all right so if it did rent
for 515 if you did get it for 50 grounds
and you didn't have to spend money doing
it up which are a few ifs you would get
29% all I'm thinking probably 25% will
be more realistic I think it's a good
house I know what do you guys think I
mean I'll tell you one thing it beat my
house which I'm a little bit annoyed
about
yeah all right
what are your names Karl Karl
column and Jeff I'm sorry Jeff Jeff all
right cool so you guys think you found
the best house you think you're amazing
whoa whoa what was the difficulty around
the whole you know group of three bed
find one friend each was together
earlier on these two are sat next to
each other in front of us I neither side
this split so sorry guys we did break
the rules listen listen I mean I'm just
trying to work out whether you broke the
rules you should be disqualified or or
or whether you are like any group of
three and you saw some on their own and
you felt bad for them I saw at the break
at one of the breaks I saw some guys
leaving yeah yeah for good
so that means for good yeah they said
they were leaving and not coming back so
that means I might have been one person
who was I just say one thing I just said
one thing really with our choice I just
had one thing really interesting we did
a we did a group count and actually no
one left someone lied to me all right do
we want to see the house or not we go
see ass but we already we're very
skeptically you guys alright so Samuel
if we've found a house that beats your
25-23 yeah and you said and everyone
likes it yeah he'd give them a hundred
quid each now know this four of us what
if we've got one with your name in as
well with my what what with your name in
with what would you then pay for it
would you give each of us well you mean
the street name was family will you men
yes I mean I depend you know what
formulas not feelings
all right give us this postcode Jewesses
postcode
alright let's get this up let's get this
up alright go ahead
s two three euh but this is the house
yeah
Samuel close very good and in Sheffield
it's not lazy Sheffield in it almost in
Leeds that would be really good one now
you're already selling it to me that's
great I said look at the conditions and
see what the guys think do you know what
a little smartphone it did a lot better
than this so we'll use that on a
smartphone it did look better on a
smartphone it look way better I mean the
guy I must say the guys aren't happy at
the minute it just came on the market
on the 31st it may be like what like six
weeks ago the guys aren't super happy
what do you think the value is of the
property properly 50 to about 50
trillion it's on for 57 so what's the
you think you just buy it for 50 Joe yes
I'm looking at what sold around the area
they're a little bit lower and also a
lot higher all right
so did you speak to the agent at all no
it didn't so wasn't sure whether or not
as part of your okay Cygnus you might be
really interested in it having your
names all right
so pass the mike nice pass to Michael
under someone else what are you
suggesting the rents gonna be on this
guy's we think about 650 650 well we can
very easily find that out what you've
given me the postcode so we're gonna go
to open rent because I'm not
crowd-pleasers today all right I will
say well say well say huh all right so
that house just to compare folks there's
a three bed terraced house what
that's gone that was like a well they
realized a student house and it's gone a
grand a month he's calm
let geez okay wow I am I am quite liking
this house
so this this is uh this is great the
month does look pretty good I mean I
don't know because of what these guys
think cuz they're the judges I
[Music]
personally think the rent I don't think
you get 650 but you might get 550 600
maybe I mean I also think you're gonna
need to spend a couple of grand here's
the thing right you're working as a
forward you should be in a three you've
you know you've upset that you've upset
the guys a few times so we do quite like
the house you've been honest about the
price you've said that the values
probably only 52 it's on for 57 so
you're probably be able to get a little
bit of a discount the rents clearly the
rents are very high 550 600 comfortably
based on what's gone so you can't
numbers don't allow you can't argue with
that so we just want to give you guys a
chance to just kind of really just
install some confidence that you're a
good team and also that this property is
really one of the best in the room so
yeah what's the ROI so though it comes
to 29 percent okay so bit of paint and
stuff bit late 25 comfortably isn't it
25 all right
so why should we what why should we
crown you guys the best house come on
grab a puzzle give me the luck it going
to invest in a property that's near
University I knew it's going to bump the
price up yeah I do like it but as well
as that there is strong employment in
Sheffield and prices are fairly low it's
a good place now
I do like Shep all right he's I'm
thinking he's not thinking I like the
house what do you guys think
oh I prefer the other group
all right here I personally really like
it I like the fact that it's cheap I
like the fact that the rents good I like
where it is but these guys I think they
want I think they want to see one more
house so you wanna see one more house
[Music]
all right what's your name
my name is Patrick Patrick say hi
Patrick Patrick how confident you about
this deal feel good feel good I think
how you feel I care what the what the
formulas I'm really confident
all right way from I'm from Bournemouth
he's from
they don't care about bombers right next
way from oh I got a little fan club over
here well Shane buddy I'm Andrew and
rewrite and we from originally Jamaica
he's from Jamaica
haha so we're gonna cut one base in
London oh well we're gonna cut you and
show you and get your names and all that
and we kick you off stage when your
house is no good so in the moment I'm
gonna need to know the postcode so get
that ready
all right go for it was supposed to go s
r2 s r2 8 n G it's nice to see a good
house for a change
all right
there's a tenant in there already paying
for 75 and it's immaculate and it's 50
grand you've got the house we didn't
have the energy and we could get it down
by five grand oh my god and they manage
the property 10 percent oh my goodness
all right all right hold on hold on oh
no so the house is on 450 thousand pound
but you spoke to the agent and they've
said that there was sell for 45 that
they'll said they're very open to offers
it's near Sunderland you think you're
going for 45 the tenant is in there
it's immaculate and the tenant is in a
twelvemonth tied to a 12-month contract
paying for 75 this is about as good as
it gets folks
all right before I mean geez like that
we don't even need to do any diligence
really know what's do we turn investment
really interesting there was another
there was another group that found the
same house now it's not necessarily who
finds the house you got a better one all
right it's not let's just say let me
tell you something I mean you need to be
able to find good houses yes you do with
the purser you'll win this game is not
the person that finds the best houses
it's the person that can't find houses
but has the most energy that's it in
property in business if you want to win
you got a big energy the reason you're
on stage and you telling me this because
you had more energy you were standing up
going our house our house a great energy
that's why on stage so if you most if
you found that he was on the same house
awesome good job good job you're great
at finding houses you just need more
energy
is that is that fair and you got Butte
you've got beautiful radians so you
could you could do this I'm surprised I
don't get your attempt you get my
attention so what did you learn bro
mister Jamaica I think the main thing
was teamwork the team makes a big
difference amazing how many of you how
many of you think that teamwork makes a
big difference raise your hand
amazing that's so true so true Beth
probably working out how much you can
actually make I love that one Beth and
did you know other these gentlemen
before today no good good could you ask
one five next Patrick a definitely
teamwork we each had a different skill
noticing things very good care attention
to detail I seem to have something of
the fire I'll phone them I'll do this
I'll do that together an unstoppable
team
listen how many of you can see these
guys they almost not have been best
friends for years and then also ago it's
incredible so here's my proposal I think
it's a fantastic house I think the fact
that you've got a beautiful condition
house you've spoke to the agent it's
still for sale they're open to 45 so
you're gonna get it for at least 46
maybe 45 it's in a great location the
tenant is fixed for 12 months I
personally would be happy to buy that
myself
I've bought nine houses in the last two
weeks I'd be very happy to make it
around ten and buy that one and I'd be
happy to give you five hundred pounds
now you've split up three ways now you
may or may not choose to go with that
you may want to buy it yourself student
venture on it you may want to wait until
tomorrow and see if you can buy it with
no money using some of the strategies
from tomorrow so obviously you guys need
to have a business meeting about that
and decide do you want to take the five
hundred pounds let me buy it
or I mean hey five hundred pounds made
in the day between the three views not
bad for an hour or do you want to buy it
yourselves one of you buy it your
adventure on it or do you want to wait
until tomorrow and see what happens so
you're gonna have to have a business
meeting about it so what we're gonna do
is I'm gonna give you a chance to have a
business meeting and your business
meeting I'm gonna give you a a total
time of 15 seconds because how many of
you how many of you know that in
business you have to make fast decisions
where's your answer I know medicine you
you hold on before you start talking
guys hey hey hey hey Beth dude Jamaican
man boy
don't start yeah don't start your
business meeting yet oh wait wait wait
listen
before you start your business me I just
wanna make a point Patrick Patrick made
a very fast decision because I said
who's got a house he jumped off and went
cars like this
he made a fast decision implemented it
in business you need some loans need to
make fast decisions so you
fifteen seconds and then when I say
please reveal your answer that's what
one of you is going to tell me the
answer but keep it secret for the
meantime for suspense 15 seconds starts
now
[Music]
[Music]
what you think they're gonna say guys
raise your hand if you would take the
money raise your hand if you would just
buy it yourself raise your hand if you
would wait until tomorrow all right
so drum roll please what's it gonna be
before we say we'll have a question is
that your best officer we think we think
it's a property that's gonna make your
lots of money for a long time
I you've given us so much today so we
won't go too honey
there's a little say we'll just say if
you offer a 600 we'll take it and we'll
all go happy because we make a lot of
money from that
all right hold on I think I'm gonna
faint I mean Jesus we are budgeted 300
that's double water budget I think I'm
in at a 15 second made him with my PI
obey all right put the music on give me
15 seconds get the music guys the
private collection
[Music]
all right
hard
listen listen guys listen guys I spoken
with my PA and she's she's the person in
fact Abby could you just run up onstage
listen this is Abby this is my PA guys
listen like you know we've we've
invested a lot of money and stuff and we
did budget 20 pounds I've spoken about
in my PA and I'm gonna let her make the
decision on this one because I mean
ultimately you know 600 pounds double we
budget for so I'll be happy to let it go
I can find it myself you know I'm very
good at this and AB you could find it
you could find a deal like that yeah I
could you know man all right and there's
other people in the room they've got
better deals
I reckon I don't know so Abby it's up to
you what you want to do I think you've
been very cheeky but we have just bought
like eight houses in the last two weeks
so we're gonna give you the 600 all
right they just made 600 I wrote on John
Rowan all right get to the back thank
you so much I got the figures everything
hit the music
[Music]
touch the person next to give my five
say you're amazing
[Music]